oh it's a four rare
[Music]
boy right let's go guys let's go you
know what i'm talking about it's a black
card
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back it's a
resident unboxer chung from gate culture
today we have something exciting for you
guys epic collaboration between dungeons
and dragons and magic the gathering i
might have played some mtg arena myself
but i have no tcg player so we have with
us today we invited one of our good
friends ted to help us with this set
booster unboxing tip would you like to
introduce yourself good thanks for
having me here my name is ted i started
playing magic gathering when i was in
secondary school and before all levels i
quit for many many years and i only came
back a few years ago
in 2018 and now i run a website called
tap and sec it helps new players get
into magic so we have articles and video
content so check it out so today we have
a really new exciting set for us this is
actually the first time magic the
gathering is introducing dungeons and
dragons into the cut game as a dmd
player magic has been in the dnd realm
for quite a while already but can you
tell us a little bit more about what
this set is about
sure so
dungeons and dragons avengers and
forgotten realms i think introduces
dnd characters and mechanics into the
magic gameplay
so you will see
cards that ask you to roll a d20 die
super exciting yeah and also there are
cards that give you a choice in deciding
what effect you want which i believe is
also
yes i can't wait
and of course you also get lots of the
legendary creatures that were only found
in yes
that is what i'm looking forward to
like like dressed and yes so
yeah so i think we're going to open
hopefully we're going to open some of
these in the packs you need to get some
good cards basically yeah and these set
boosters also have um different
items inside for one of them is the art
card so this is the art card
it's basically a card that showcases
the art that are found on the magic
cards themselves
so they are expanded and for people to
enjoy there's also a chance that you can
get more than one rare in set boosters
compared to the draft boosters whereby
usually you only get one where i see i
see so more value in the set boosters
okay so this is more for me for dnd
player this is what i'm looking for
it depends what you want but i think in
terms of value the set boosters offer a
great value okay now for the money that
you use awesome before we get into the
unboxing a word from our sponsors jackie
you take it away this video is brought
to you by secret lab now here at geek
culture we do love our secret lab chairs
we use it for work we use it for gaming
and pretty much everything that we do
what we like about the chess is that
secret lab offers different sizes from
the omega to the titan and the titan xl
you can also customize the material with
prime 2.0 pu leather and their super
plush fabric soft weave not only that
they've got designs of all your favorite
esports teams and special editions
themed after league of legends world of
warcraft dc batman and even game of
thrones
so there's definitely a chair for you so
do check out secret lab link in the
description below
alright introductions aside let's get
down to business and pull ourselves some
chiamat from this box man so this is our
very first pack we're going to open it
now and for the first few packs we'll go
a bit slower and go through the cards
and tell you what what they are and
point out any valuable cards hopefully
you'll get some in the start right yeah
all right so let's go what if you do get
so much from the first pack so the first
part you'll end the video
that's it yeah we ended up high right so
we just stopped already yeah
okay so oh what is this can you tell us
something about this is this new
i believe this is a dnd this is a dnd
stat card actually yeah
so what we normally do when we open
packs is we're trying to figure out
which one is the front and back oh so
it's not very clear right now because
both sides have something on it right
but this is the token and okay this is
the back okay so i think this is the
back okay this is the front this is the
front so we know let me go by the front
yeah and then we'll hit the okay we hit
the land first so this is our basic land
you need this lens to cast uh spells by
tapping for mana right oh and then our
very first card is uh
it's a rule book uh right this is also
from dnd
yeah it's a character this is called the
alternate art version every set has
right its own kind of alternate art and
for dnd they went to look at the old
rule book right and put it into a magic
this would be super familiar to like dnd
players especially the old editions i
think yeah nice nice this is super old
school yeah and then they also have for
this set only some flavor text which
dark ones only right so this is uh more
exclusive to this expansion right like
the previous one we don't have all these
usually they won't write these flavor
tags here they would just describe the
effects straight away i see just for
this dnd set they put in some of that
dna awesome this is so awesome okay all
right so we've got our first cards are
uncommon and then we've got a common
circle
yeah these are commons you can tell from
the black right symbol all right and
these were the choice cards that was
talking about wherever
you cast this spell and they asked you
to choose one
right um so depending on what your
gameplay situation is you can pick one
that suits you better and this is also
new to
magic it's less commonly seen
okay it's not completely new because
there are cards in the past where they
offer you a choice but normally one card
will have one effect
but in this dnd set i think they want to
open it to newer players so yeah it's
more we get to see these cards more yeah
i see it's more flexible right gamepl
ah it's amazing though yeah lots of da
is always amazing yeah yeah magic is
something in in uh it's always like it's
one of the drawers of magic yeah so
people really love the art and they buy
cards just to get out you know yeah
also like foot rope this is the very
first card we've seen with that uses the
d20 mechanic
so okay for example it says whenever
lightfoot rope attacks when so when this
creature attacks roll the d20 awesome
depending on what you roll
you get the effect that effect awesome
so what do we get for 20. so 20 is the
hardest to get obviously right
so you can get the three
to the power plus one zero and gains
first strike and death touch
wow okay this is also a very big one
right yeah yeah
but super cool this is so cool yeah but
i guess even if you roll a one to nine
or ten times it's still not bad right
you can do that yeah yeah okay
okay i see yeah so you'll see a lot of
small cards with these rolling a d20
um adds more randomness to the game
um probably good for beginners but not
so good for season players because who
they want to know yeah they want to know
what they want
okay this is still kind of exciting even
for a dnd player yeah yeah
all right so there's another artifact
equipment
all right um let's go through no hunter
it's a two-two creature
all right another d20 detective yeah
okay so this one's a one-time spell a
sorcery and you return it to your
owner's hand or its owner puts it puts
it a picture on top of the bottom of the
library or gain control of that creature
for one until the end of your next turn
yeah so pretty good so i think we might
be hitting our rare okay so what we
normally do is we look at the bottom oh
at the peak so it tells you whether it's
uncommon or rare rare will be r and m is
mythic rare so it's gonna go on amazing
yeah so just reveal it quick
and it's
sharp
laughter
all right it's a tree casting cost each
opponent exiles cuts from the top of the
library until that players accept cards
with total mana value 20 or more so this
card is good for one of the winning
strategies called mail where you okay
try to get the opponent's cards into the
description yeah right okay until he has
no more cuts okay okay awesome yeah so
we do have one more foil card i believe
every set every pack has a cut okay so
we might see it now well
if it's another rare or another mystic
where i don't know the exact odds
but i think it's fairly reasonably
common okay yeah maybe
one out of four one okay let's go let's
do this
i feel it it's yeah
okay so the four you can see is shiny
this is the stack cards that we have
earlier this was the oh this is a token
card yeah the token so i think the last
card is either a token or an ad okay or
a card from the list going to a second
type second fact exciting
yep all right uh i
cut okay oh oh it says uh
signature on it so this is the
stem signature oh wow i'm not sure what
card it is because it doesn't say about
that critical critical here
nice if you roll 20 you get a critical
hit on attack rules
yeah oh you ready okay that's not a
critical hit yeah yeah awesome this is
awesome so every set booster pack will
have one of these cards and mostly they
are not signed but this one is a sign
awesome are these available they are not
as so bad but they're just like
collectible value very nice to look at
yeah yeah yeah you can decorate your
boxes
right and put an album yeah perhaps okay
we have this
basic land yeah so every pack will have
a basic length nice okay ours is four
first one oh we get our rule book arbors
per gases
our blurrier gases yeah so commonly nice
adventure
moving walls land
right our basic common
beautiful behavior holder well it's a
common common deal it has the behavior
it's not the xenotherapy holder but it's
still a builder in case you guys didn't
know
our our brand our mascot geek cultures
mascot is beholden so we're going to get
in senator man i feel it i feel like i
hope so too yeah i hope you hope the
hope you open
my guts yeah we're going to get it
all right we got more
d20 cards lots of them
[Music]
and you got some abilities to pay one
life to create a treasure or you can pay
mana to give a target plus two plus zero
at the end of turn nice correct me if
i'm wrong treasure tokens are new to the
expansion or is it oh it's all okay now
what they do is they can you can
sacrifice it and sacrifice it to create
one mana of any kind right awesome so it
helps you cast spells okay that's cool
okay
oh we got a four rare oh my gosh it's a
gelatinous cube guys and there's a cube
from dnd it's a kind of dnd right this
is the thing we don't want to see in dnd
it's too strong
this is awesome this is awesome and it's
in the rule book right alternative form
yeah right
so it's a it's a creature for two two
generic two black and four tree and when
it enters the battlefield exile target
non-use creature and opponent controls
until this leaves the battlefield so in
a way it's like you get your creature
and you can remove the opponent's
creature as well awesome you just have
to protect it yeah and it also has the
ability to play eggs and black to put
thai creature cut with mana value x
except with this
card into the graveyard so after you
exit out the opponent's card you can pay
more mana to
destroy it completely right right oh so
nice our first foreign
in afr so later we will see cards where
they say venture into the dungeon and
when you venture into dungeon you take
this out from your
outside of the game you just put into
play and you start on the first room
right so what do we get yeah so the very
first room each player loses one life
okay so it doesn't sound good yeah yeah
i think this particular
tomb of annihilation yeah is more you
get some drawbacks the benefit is you
can finish the dungeon quite quickly it
only takes one two three steps so what
do we get at the end of the legend so
when you finish at the end of the
dungeon you said create a tropical
legendary four for black
touch so you get a free creature and
also you've considered to have completed
a dungeon right so there are cards that
say when you've completed dungeon do
this you get a bet
so like an additional
benefit yeah cool cool cool so sometimes
people want to rush through the dungeon
yeah to get that benefit right so we'll
see more of that later okay second
second booster is pretty good yes yep
all right let's just go into our next
pattern
oh
cut first
guys it's all pointing to getting the
xenophon man we have the b i of the b
holder we have the art card
come on so many beholders already yeah
yeah okay this is a new kind of card
newly introduced in afr okay it's called
a class card um so for this one it's
called barbarian class right and what
you do is when you cast this you get
this first ability
but you have the choice to spend more
mana to get level two and level three oh
you want to spend
that's pretty cool yeah so i've seen
some games where uh some of these class
cards are really powerful yeah once you
level up i see and they are not too
difficult to level up right like yeah
one two minus yeah this one just costs
one by class
two next one level two is two and then
level three is three so other other
class cards will have different costs
depending on the students yeah
oh critical oh there you go
yeah
so i'll look out for the one where we
venture into the dungeon but first
dragon yeah oh so adventures in the fog
realms has lots of dragons yeah
so every color has its own dragon yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah red dragon blue dragon and
that's not all you also have uh higher
rarity dragons dominating rare dragons
and hopefully we'll have to see
ultimately
it's one of the dragons right yeah it's
here man oh we got a mythic
okay okay i think i've seen that before
grand master right right right this is
nice
grandmaster
he's a character and yeah i think he's a
character
oh i think this might be his like
apparition or something okay
yeah i i can't i'm not really too chill
so i did
i didn't read about bahamut being a
quite a famous yeah it's like the
opposite opposite side of uh
yeah nice okay all fours are uncommon
uncommon form
just troll man's out the troll this is
the choice
okay so you can use this for treasure
tokens all right awesome awesome
so not bad we open our first mythic rare
already
it's just i think this is a
oh nice white dragon so this is the
borderless version of cards it's amazing
where there's no border right
um it's very nice yeah white dragon
awesome
okay let's see if we have any cards that
venture into the dungeon
so we're getting our comments and our
comments there's lots of comments also
mentions venture into the dungeon
but it stops the opponent from going to
the dungeon so each opponent can't
venture into the dungeon more than once
each turn
so normally if you have multiple effects
you can just going going to the next
room right but this card stops
from going more than once yeah okay so
we'll go on to the rest of the pack
split the party you never split the
party
[Music]
never see the parking you never spin the
party
okay let's see it's a rare where do we
that's a have
that uses the d20 mechanic i see
one you lose three life what two to nine
you create five changes which is very
good oh five treasures so basically okay
this is three months okay and 10 to 19
you get three life and draw three cards
right and 20 the best is search for
library for card oh this is good right
this is good right it's not bad um the
problem is that you have to pay for and
sacrifice this to roll the date oh i see
quite a lot of course okay okay i'll
is it hard to form a deck with a set
booster like this it's not hard uh you
can create a simple deck okay with one
whole box of boosters
yeah so it's not difficult and you can
try to form your deck revolving around
the mechanics of this set so maybe you
want your deck to be lots of dice
dungeons
or you want your deck to be about
dungeons right generating value from
dungeons so you can build a deck around
that you know awesome okay
and now we got planes
bruno battle hammer this guy is
legendary dwarf guy yeah with with
alongside this yeah he's very good in
this uh magic card actually because he
plays off equipment
so
each creature you control gets plus two
plus zero for each equipment attached i
see and he may pay zero basically free
yeah rather than pay the equip cost of
the first ability to activate issues oh
wow so every equipment you throw for the
first time for your turn is
free i mean the equipment so
putting it putting it to the right right
yeah
each turn first time each turn so very
good crazy here i know i mean i know a
lot of people want to use this in their
commander i see
yes i mean well it's uncommon so not
hard not good not yet
but
okay
lots of dnd references
yeah all right super cool
common so this is equipment you will see
here equipment i see yeah yeah
and then there's a quick cost
so with bruno instead of paying this you
pay zero i think yeah where is
circle of dreams druid we have
yeah
but it's been predicted to be one of the
more powerful cuts in other formats i
see some formats because it allows you
to tap at green mana for each creature
you control wow so you have lots of
creatures it's going to add a lot of
money wow okay okay right the only
downside is uh
okay and if you kill off the creature
then you lose that ability i see but
it's very powerful awesome common force
all right this is our list a card from
the list oh okay so instead booster
packs we get there's a chance to get a
card from the list okay and you also
know about what what's the least yeah so
you can tell whether it's from the list
by this little icon at the bottom okay
it looks a bit more old like right yeah
and the list contains cards from the
entire history of magic it was picked
out by wizards by some formula yeah know
okay so it can contain a lot of random
cards right and there are some valuable
ones and there are some that just it's
common guys yeah just not worth anything
so for this one uh parallel evolution
it's on a very old set i do even i think
torment the performance event expansion
set so this old frame was the original
frame of magic cards back in the 90s
yeah it looks bold yeah it looks like
yeah yeah yeah
they call it retro but all right to me
it looks good this is the
so i've not seen this card before but
it's a sorcery for each creature token
play his controller puts another token
plate as a copy of that creature awesome
so it looks pretty good yeah it's
so i'm not sure of the value but we'll
get two rest from this booster actually
yeah yeah so that's not too bad right is
so fast not bad yeah so hopefully yeah
let's go
yeah hopefully we open more cards from
the list because the list has some
valuable cuts oh i see yeah okay okay
and you don't see them very often
okay how are you
foil forest
no hunter i think we've seen this yeah
oh there again again really dragon yeah
real frost nice spell oh
no this is uh i'm not sure if this is a
character in dnd but it could be but i'm
not too familiar right yeah so one of
the new mechanics in this set is called
tactics whatever
attacks if you attack with creatures
with total power six or greater this
combat you get this benefit attacking
could just get plastic oh wow okay so
like a few creatures that all attacking
together gets all these plus one yeah if
the total power is six number six okay
and there are quite a lot of cards with
these pack tactics i see uh mechanic so
just now you're talking about building
deck from the set if you find lots of
cards with tech tactics you could make
quite a good intention
awesome yep equipment dueling rapier
modern kindness polymorph this is spell
flavor
and after entire creature becomes a
dragon
with base power toughness four four
against flying okay
oh oh where is nadar it's a rule book
frame card
no it's not for
three non-foreign for tree tree whenever
it enters the battlefield or text
venture into the dungeon so you can do
it okay
yeah okay awesome
and then you see uh other creatures you
control your plus one plus one as long
as you've completed a dungeon oh so
that's why you wanna sometimes you want
to complete the dungeons yeah four is a
common lane evolving miles
all right it's all right it's all right
yeah that's all right okay going to our
next pack
i see a stat card is it a stat card
there's a token yeah that's at the back
so our art card is nice cool someone
being bashed up yeah
swan doing skeletons okay our comments
multiple comments trolls
sales channel
good
all right and i think our rare okay we
have a rare
meteorite
wow eight damage looks pretty good they
are divided as you choose among x target
creatures of planeswalkers oh okay you
can spread it out depending on how many
mana you casted yeah how much you do
okay
so you can have x to be zero or as much
as you want nice as long as you have the
mana foil is
common oh man come to a river what do
you do
another rpg cut yeah lots i sense the
beholder
nice oh it's that cut yeah yeah all
right oh green wow borderless this is
awesome this is amazing so we really had
a white dragon yeah now we got the green
i feel like we can kind of form like
like like a dragon deck here all you
need is a tiarama now
okay monk breeze and dwarf
whoa
is this good in mtg actually i think in
some formats uh i think commander some
people are trying to build around him oh
okay because in commander you can have
so many different cards right so it's
not difficult to have to fulfill this i
see commander decks are the ones with
the commander yeah conan deck is the one
where you have a commander that sits
outside basically your hero right it's
outside your deck and you can cast it
directly from the so it's a bit
different from the standard decks yes
it's a bit different
fall is oh awkward jelly which is just
this oil right
right it's shiny right yeah yeah
although it's a very mild kind of
strength yeah it looks like the cube
but it's a rare so it's quite good yeah
foil rare i'm going to put this down
here
are you familiar with volo yeah okay
it's extremely popular in the end okay
okay goblin javelina bull string
you see a guard grab a guard approach
what do you do what do you do yeah do
you always ask that yeah what do you do
yeah okay yeah like how do you do this
what do you want to do and then it has
to be decided by the four people yeah
the party will decide or whoever is like
the situation i see
for example where is
is attacking alone the video is covered
by damage to a player venturing to the
dungeon nice
it comes to a normal camp
not too valuable i assume yeah usually
the foil commons are not too good
not variable maybe like i know there are
30 packs here you know in a box so
nice art cart mountain so actually i
want to say that the mount the lens in
this set they have just a flavor text
here the puff you know just something
right usually usually there's no
there's no description or anything
so just for this set they added this
flavor text yeah
okay nice
nice pink dog beast
hunter smart hunter's map long rest is
you turn x target creature cuts with
different mother values from a graveyard
to your hand if eight or more cards
return their hand this way your life
tutorial becomes equal to your starting
life total
is it super strong in terms of magic
well it has x casting course so you
really need to spend a lot of mana i see
but if you do have that mana you can
return x different cards with different
mana values to your hand so it's kind of
more given yeah and you can have x
equals eight then uh your life total
goes back to your original starting life
total okay so from 20 if you went down
to ten you can go back to twenty
yeah i haven't seen this guy either
who's like probably too strong for my
idea
i've seen this play in the arena
actually oh okay you paid three which is
very cheap to get a five five but yeah
so strong what's the but if it's if you
haven't completed a dungeon you have to
return it to your hand and then venture
into the dungeon so you get a free
venturing oh okay yeah and then once you
get him on the board when he attacks um
for each opponent you create a two-two
zombie creature or says the player sexy
creature so yeah so actually we have one
rare and we have one mythic rare in this
wow so this is actually so this is
right right
and we haven't hit the floor yeah
exactly yeah we haven't even hit a four
yeah yeah so our foil is uh let's go
common
[Music]
find the path
i mean getting getting a rare animated
ring yeah
is it in this pack well maybe we'll find
out yeah we'll find out very soon
okay
oh where is westgate region 4-4 vampire
i think not not that great but if you
want vampire decks you
let's go you know what i'm talking about
it's a black card
we have that but this is the regular
yeah it looks so good this looks so good
though regular we have two of these now
we got two yeah so we've got three four
rests wow that's awesome yes yeah okay
but in terms of mythic rares we've only
hit two which is which is the grand
grand master of flowers and uh
is also a mythic rare uh he is a rarity
he's rare okay i'm not sure hopefully
we'll open it and then we'll find out
yeah
maybe we'll find out i mean we're gonna
get it
it's little a rare okay
loyal warhounds dog 31 vigilance when it
enters the battlefield if a bono
controls more land than you you can
search for planes and put in battlefield
cats
yeah
common foil what is this displacer beast
oh yeah so just a cat beast too okay so
far we have only hit one list card
so
so i assume it's uh it's quite low it's
kind of hard to get yeah yeah i mean i
know it's not every pack and yeah maybe
like one in every four or five packs
yeah normally we should have hit one
more one yeah
so if
lacking in the list cards hopefully we
get some now medical
potion paladin double paladins nice
wanderer amar
human wizard okay
oh bruno another one yeah so this is the
regular version right
a dark gold dragon there you go another
dragon all signs
who leads to the tiamat and the zenith
this is our rare so okay
what's behind another rare another
super strong spell indian is it strong
in in magic well it caused sex but you
can copy another target artifact or
creature so one of your creatures become
another
creature so the opponent has the
powerful yeah you can copy it okay
awesome this is pretty awesome yeah it's
not bad
well common okay okay
okay
oh our first module what is this our
module frame i believe from dmv used to
be the old yeah
yes and for some of the lens
this set they
put in this um
custom this is so cool
do they have this art style in the
monsters or like creatures actually just
for them yeah just for lands and only
some of the lands okay so this is the
first one we've opened yeah i believe
this is the first one yeah yeah so it's
actually not that easy to get yeah right
i thought it would be more common
wow nice yeah
looks nice oh yeah we'll put it here
[Music]
okay this is our rare look common
oh rare six six as
mornings guys
yeah this is a character from dnd right
yes right evil evil he's actually pretty
powerful yeah oh for for magic yeah oh
um i think in commander some people
are also thinking of building around
here around him i see
what's also for common
core
it's all right we've got smoothies
yeah
okay
red dragon balls guys come on
we have all the dragons
yeah blue we have white we have green
yeah not the five calendar yeah
but we have all five which means tiana
is coming guys
what if we don't hit it
i'm going to call the users of the
course
ask them to give them give us another
box yeah yeah we need
guys if you want to watch more you know
what to do
treasure vault is our rare artifact land
where you can create exchanges nice yeah
oh second rare zone
it's familiar in dnd okay yeah it's a
creature if you create one or more
treasure tokens instead create those
tokens plus one so basically an
additional treasure here amazing art for
comment common folder all right this is
our list card so
this is our second list it's also an old
card it looks a bit different it's the
newer card this is from
m20 so our newest set is a tree 33
creature so it's only uncommon so like i
said the list is very random you can get
comments on comments or rares any chance
to get like fall from from the list yeah
i think i don't think so usually it's
non-fine okay yeah
we have like three different styles of
the cube yeah
mango class
yeah so we already talked about class
cards and this is a rare uh for the
monks
another rare vocals oh wow this is a
very famous swat right yeah
yeah yeah it's also the buy a box promo
for this set
buy a box promo so usually when you buy
a box um if the store has stock they
give you this free
out of the box i know it's a it's a
fixed card so it's second maybe
i see yeah it's a different art oh okay
but there are limited quantities so so
you don't normally usually get yeah we
have the pre-order okay okay the box and
then they will give it to you wait but
it's not in one of the boosters it's
separate they'll give you the cut
separately yes correct
and also you can also open vocals what
within that is right yeah it's the
regular awesome yeah it looks cool so we
got two rares and yeah
okay
we need some mythic rares yes guys come
on
show us
we have five dragons now all we need is
guardian of faith is our rare i see it
looks cool it looks cool and it's
actually a pretty usable card because
when it enters the battlefield any
number of other time creatures you
control phase out so phase out means
that they kind of disappear and cannot
be affected by the opponent oh wow so we
can save your creatures right when they
try to kill it three mile after cars
okay street fortunately it's pretty
strong yeah actually it's very good
value yeah what's next what's next
another rare awesome one let's go
westgate region oh we've seen this yeah
okay all right
no worries we still have about still
quite a lot of yeah like maybe 10 packs
you know like we're like and we have uh
yeah yeah we have like session five yeah
okay like one third or one third oh back
up stash of cards and they're about like
20 36 or uh 30 in the set three
yeah
okay are we hitting the rare now nope
it's too common
oh there's a rare record
dungeon descent it's a land oh it's cool
so you can tap for colorless mana or you
can tap an untapped legendary creature
you control venture into the dungeon
okay it helps you venture yeah better
than a normal land card for sure
okay well common
ah this is my kick for opening packs
oops
sign card
which is our rare you may play a card
you own from outside the game distance
so when they say outside the game
meaning like not in your deck or what so
you can have cards out of your deck and
you can yes because outside of your deck
you also have this thing called
sideboard i see a substitution you know
yeah so after every game you can
substitute in
to match your wow isn't it very strong
i think so well we haven't seen in play
much okay it's new it's new card it's
not a reprint
so we're not sure how powerful you'll be
if you have lots of mana here you can
spend three to cast this and then use
the what's left to cast that spell that
you like yeah
so what do we have next another rare
paladin class
we have about almost all the classes
right there are quite a lot of classes
um so we don't have all i think but we
do have quite a few we have like the
monk the druid
the barbarian
yeah wizard yeah paladin some are rare
some are uncommon so the rails will be
harder to get southern rare is good this
is good for common
oh and this is our list card oh this
looks a very old card this is stampede
so two mana um
you can buy back meaning if you
sacrifice the land you can bring this
spell back to your hand after you've
cast it and then put a pegasus token to
play it's a one-on-one creature
yeah
old school yeah so it's like yeah that's
amazing
yeah we think rare come on whenever we
get into stop teasing us like this
we have all the dragons guys
black black dragon
well actually we didn't have black
dragon oh yeah yeah yeah but now we do
now we do
white dragon guys it's this pack
it's gonna be this pack
it has to be this pack
okay i feel it
my thing where come on oh this i'm
coming okay it's not yet okay no yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's beautiful very rare
[Music]
we started off like so strong yeah yeah
yeah grand master
yeah
we went downhill
so this is a very famous yes a very very
famous character
i believe yeah
yeah this is awesome is this available
um we have to check i think it's a rare
it's not as valuable okay it's easier to
get but it's quite powerful yeah it's
too amazing
to be honest yeah in fact i just read
about the original art of this piece it
was just sold for quite a lot of money i
think i might have seen that
yes yes yes
it's insane
nice full comments let's go let's go to
our next pack we should don't have many
yeah we have like
one two three four five six seven eight
packs left yeah well one third this is
the last last last
nine yeah nine last pack right what are
the odds for getting like a mythic right
so far we only got like two
yeah i think normally by now we should
have at least four maybe so we're a bit
full below average
so
lightly let's hope that let's hope we
get yeah some of these over here yeah
another
damage venture into the dungeon okay so
it's a playing with the dungeon mechanic
yeah
another
guys this is super popular in indian
development i think there's more than
one wagner yeah yeah yeah i know so it's
one of them and then there's another one
here
you find the villains there right we're
going to eat into our
reserve packs guys we need the milky
ways we need the tail mark it's got to
be in one of these boosters i can smell
it man
oh boy
mimic okay
all right barbarians smite vine smile
scryder
valorous singer
come on
not yet yeah
rare ranger class okay
this is one of the more powerful
clusters right because it gives you a
token and then after that every time you
attack it pumps up your creatures i see
plus some plus one i see yeah
is there a butt plus yeah yeah okay but
we haven't yeah we didn't see it so most
of the common classes are in in the
booster in this expansion yeah class is
a new type of cut right right so okay
you will find all the class cards in
this set awesome
uh ranger's hawk
this is uncommon
dragon queen we have this i think we
have we have these right sure uncommon
also we might have drawn it dragon queen
guys you know what that means
mythic red yama incoming no rare oh this
is the module lane
wow this is awesome awesome though i
love that
is this like good in terms of this one
is the blue version of the module lens
and what the the lens do is they can you
can pay mana to convert it to a creature
so this one becomes a seventh is so
amazing it's so nostalgic like yeah yeah
super petrol did you play during this no
no no no i'm like a modern i'm like
fifth edition this is like i don't know
this is like first second or third right
yeah because i'm looking at images
online and the other the actual books
yeah oh yeah but it's amazing you see
it's just beautiful yeah this is amazing
okay
oh we got a oh this card all right this
looks good this is mythic right semantic
rare come on
yeah this one i'm not sure the value but
it is quite
used quite a lot in color
so it allows you to
when you add three counters on it you
can sacrifice it and take back creatures
from all graveyards and put it under
your control so all graveyard yeah it's
meaning
wow okay this is awesome just that you
you need to get it to three counters
right discarding a card okay this last
four packs man that's fine
borderless
yeah i should be nice to get a tmi i
have to be honest here
oh power kill
okay are we going to our rare not yet
still rare
skeletal swarming okay this one is
uncharming um but in gameplay it can be
quite annoying because it creates it
creates more and more skeletons oh okay
every time your turn okay so it's very
difficult for the opponent to get rid of
it unless they have a
child removal spell okay yeah come on
oh okay there you go
we needed it man we need a camera
bear hunter mark fly
and now where ultimate bar class class
is just talking about this yeah
so this is great pretty much in most of
the classes i think there are some ways
okay we're going to our third last pack
yes
come on we need to get the good ones
here tiana has to be here we can do this
yes you can do this mythic rare yeah
mythicware
mythicware come on oh yeah let's go
let's go but what is it is it is it
come on
oh my god
isn't it it is but i don't think it's a
multicolored oh
it's green
is it green i see a bit of green oh this
green is probably one of the dragons
yeah i think it's the normal dragon okay
yes yeah right all right
no tiamat but still there's the green
dragon here yep green dragon
still pretty good super good no tiana
it's okay
they like to tease us we have two more
packs we might have something else at
the bottom yes another one
four
four two yeah this this pack is good
five more let's go
and
when i was playing in 1998. wow
1998. yeah so i think a lot of you were
not born
like maybe five years old almost four
years ago yeah like six years old yeah
yeah i was in a secondary school at that
time so i was playing with these cards
you know
serious paper store yeah and if i win i
think we open the right one all right
okay let's go see this paper
you win okay so we're going to take this
one it's guys i feel it
all these dragons
and
they don't just appear for nothing
somebody summoned them
and it's tiana believe me
but no
yeah come on
[Music]
class okay pretty cool yeah
so this is the same as the
this lens but it's a red version
this is a normal frame
so you can also convert to a creature so
there's there's also one with uh this
frame yes oh okay and there's one for
each color and one for each uh frame on
the other side
awesome
they think right behind
is it meeting right right right oh this
is two right meaning of the mighty so
yes uh yeah the pack tactics were also
just one of the packs yeah you can
attack with total power sticks or
greater then you can
put a creature card from your hand onto
the battlefield for free wow but it's
hard to i guess it's harder to pull it
off yeah that's true yeah
anything else behind and
uncommon
clearing okay
[Music]
oh another list cut but it's a common
official change so you see you get a lot
of these random cards and yeah you don't
know whether they're going to go
we did get some good ones yeah a bit
more and uh
dice the last pack last pack a very good
last pack three with us
why did we get a temple of the dragon
queen it's because tiamat is in it
this is amazing this is super man yeah
it looks cool yeah it looks super good
fits well with camera
okay
slowly going towards the last mimic or
back there all right what's next it's
going to be tiamat mythic
one of the dnd characters okay yeah yeah
this one lets you search your
library for artifacts
yeah put it onto the battlefield but you
have to sacrifice one artifact oh get
another artifact okay of higher value
what do you have next oh it's a rare
uncommon
critical heat
and on a downward critical hit us with
all these
and that's it
our box but
okay i mean we got some good cards so in
terms of value
is is this like is this a good draw it
could be better could be better right
because we did not hit
[Music]
and all these dragons and they didn't
give us the dragon right and we didn't
hit some of the other mythic rares um
that are worth more like the spider
queen
yeah right i mean i think i'm quite
happy with the pack quite a bit raw yeah
they can be better but yeah i could have
been better but but i feel like some of
the cards are really really amazing like
no matter
like whether the value is there or not
yeah like they look super good i think
just just being able to hold the
volume yeah exactly as a dnd player
these all these cards look super good
it's very different even the common
cards like some of them are super
amazing like you can even use them as
tokens and stuff like that i think yeah
that's it folks thank you guys for
watching the video if you like what you
see don't forget to leave a like drop a
comment down below and subscribe to the
channel because we have a couple more
boxes of these and thanks dad for
joining us in this unboxing session even
though we didn't get any chiama yeah it
was a bit sad today but thanks for
having me today it was nice to open the
cards and the packs even before release
date and really excited about some of
the mechanics that we'll see in future
games don't forget to check out his
website guys yes my website happens it's
a website for magic new magic players so
check it out we've got lots of good
stuff there awesome so that's it guys we
will see you in the next video
bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
you